[Music]
here in the waters of the LEM Bay
straight and North Sulawesi Indonesia
we've come to observe an animal that has
learned to survive by carrying its
defense on its back this is the carrier
crab it's two back legs are specially
modified to carry anything it can put
between itself and harm's way a piece of
dead coral seaweed a broken shell but
sometimes that thing is alive here's a
carrier crab toting a sea urchin a
seemingly unwitting participant being
used as an underwater defense shield
watch how the carrier crab uses the sea
urchin spines as a weapon when it's
threatened and if that doesn't work the
carrier crab conveniently Nestle's into
the sand leaving its trusty defense
shield exposed